[Music]
so two weeks ago one person accused
Brett Kavanaugh of committing a sex
crime in 1982 the four other people
present denying it happened those are
the facts we have on the table for this
the left has called him a sex criminal
an attempted rapist and tried to destroy
his life he fought back yesterday
now his persecutors have a new argument
watch we know one thing he does not have
the temperament to be a judge he
basically had a tantrum and showed that
he doesn't have the temperament to be a
Supreme Court justice he just felt like
oh well that's what he's like when he's
angry and belligerent when he's drunk
his temperament is just not suited my
opposition solidified because of
temperament and fitness which I believe
he lacks senator Blumenthal fresh from
caisson delivering his verdict here
Chris Hahn is an attorney radio host and
former aide to Senator Chuck Schumer he
joins us tonight so I think this is the
most Orwellian argument maybe I've ever
seen so you attack the guy is a sex
criminal an attempted rape as to drunk
someone who's unfit not just to be a
Supreme Court justice but to live in
this country and when he gets mad about
it and defends himself you say look at
him he's an abuser because he got mad
like what it's too unfair actually well
when you weak on the law pound the facts
when you're weak on the facts pound the
law when you're weak on both pound the
table and scream like hell that's what
he did
judges are not supposed to scream like
hell they're not supposed to be partisan
like he was and it was quite frankly a
disappointing display by Judge Cavanaugh
one that no judge would ever accept I
worked in the federal courts I worked in
the state courts I have never seen
anything like that that is nice
something except me can I just say this
was not in the head of jurist
okay but the level-headed jurist was
just accused of a sex crime he says he
didn't commit his reputation has been
destroyed
he will never work again unless he gets
this job you know that to be true if I
said hey Chris well
told me anonymously that you're a rapist
and I'm gonna tell your kids about it
until they don't like you anymore
and your neighbors won't speak to you
and you would I mean he would be very
upset I would be upset it happened to me
I was upset and it's okay because it's
like vitamin to be upset and then I
would not be behaving I would not be
behaving like a Supreme Court judicial
nominee he is a Supreme Court judicial
nominee who should always present
themselves so how I'm senators patient
senators behave should senators be
especially members of district committee
should to be honest right
should they be fair Shetty's right
should I start trying to destroy their
voters will accept senators senators
stand before the voters and are approved
by the voters this man stands before
Congress the standard is mine he's going
for a lifetime appointment sir a
lifetime appointment Tucker is the most
revealing answer I got oh yeah it's
Friday I'm just at the end of the show
this long just to get a really clear
answer makes you behave whatever vote I
like I like to give you you know I
always give you a clear answer but
here's but but here is the President of
the United States Donald Donald Trump
said specifically there should be no
doubt how can we have no doubt after
yesterday I'm sorry there's plenty of
doubts at this of capital they're really
actually countries does that mean this
I'm not a partisan Republican I don't
really like the Republicans very much
but I watched him yesterday and I really
felt for him and I turn on the other
channels they're like white privilege we
don't see the same way Harlem Tucker I
mean the question is questioning dibbley
for her so I believe Turtwig I believe
her I think she thinks she's telling the
truth there's no evidence she's telling
the truth but I believe she believes it
that doesn't make it true there's it's
an important distinction yeah I've
always thought she meant so what I'm
sorry for her any erratic time Chris
thank you most people who are reliving a
traumatic experience will not have
evidence of it 30 years later let's no
evidence required no just the accusation
thank you